ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great
views such great news I was proven even
more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
there is actually igniting my father so
maybe I was wrong maybe prayer does work
right communist level of this is
[Music]
this is
communist level of this is
communist level
[Music]
God forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donnie
boy great orange leader Dear God
forbid Donny boy God forbid Donny boy
communist level this is like
communism
[Music]
this is
communist level of I think that's
about all we need to hear
you gotta get a moment
great to be here
[Music]
now
do you like the fact that us has like
more today no
thank you
you're saying that the middle folder
doesn't matter at all
[Music]
seriously keep going
keep going
[Music]
what are you talking about
that's insane
[Music]
failure
I think you're missing the pressure
[Music]
I love mangoes too
the American people alive
[Music]
bring my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango
[Music]
ES
huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I have with me David packman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show and I wanted to talk
to David packman
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta man they go along with
homosexuality hold on Buddy
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog but enough a dozen because he's
a logical thinking and they're
controlled by the darkness of David
Pac-Man
he is
[Music]
David Patman is
David you're not here to communicate I
really appreciate you coming on I'm
going to let you go to waste of time to
talk to you we're not communicating
you're acting like that because you're
asking bizarre questions
and you wasting my time
all right goodbye
[Applause]
that's a progressive boat all men who
are progressive all right everybody
enough of that we are here because Ron
DeSantis Rob Des sanctimonious Ron Des
Sanctus meetball Ron Ron dishonest you
got you know what I'm talking about he
is announcing his candidacy for the
presidency of the United States
momentarily he is doing so in a less
than typical fashion something's very
wrong with my hair
um he is going to be doing it on Elon
musk's Twitter momentarily as you can
see scheduled for just 12 minutes from
now
and uh I have absolutely no idea what to
expect for those questioning whether
DeSantis truly is running here is the
statement of organization filed today at
2 33 p.m Eastern Time Ron DeSantis for
president based in Tallahassee Florida
uh this is a Republican party candidacy
seeking the presidential office
the treasurer is Caitlin torterichi and
desantis's grift funds will be kept at
Chain Bridge bank in McLean Virginia if
anybody has any further questions about
that
contact Caitlyn I don't know I don't
know what to tell you so he is indeed
running let's look at some of the early
reaction to this here is Marjorie Taylor
green slamming to Sanctus because he is
announcing on Twitter you don't announce
that you're running for president of the
United States
in some kind of little Twitter world
it's not a real world Twitter is not
real so I can't comprehend why that
would be the place to do the
announcement it makes no sense it's not
serious that's there you go and as we
know Marjorie Taylor green there is no
better Arbiter of what is serious than
Marjorie Taylor green by the way
yesterday she said that she didn't wear
the vaccine
I don't even know what that means but
okay then we go to Fox News Fox News
also ridiculing that this will happen on
uh Twitter spaces hey Lucas so he's
going to make the big announcement with
Elon Musk at six o'clock tonight on
Twitter spaces
what the heck is Twitter spaces
I wish I knew more basketball
I think he's true
uh explosive reporting from Fox News
sounds like a video function yeah right
yeah
we're streaming and some podcasts and
that kind of thing I think it's
fascinating that they're using social
media as a way to announce it's just
absolutely fascinating as you can see
Donald Trump rolling out a new
anti-disant Assad really uh the
floodgates have opened wherein he
attacks DeSantis as a swamp creature
Trump defeats the
2016. president Trump defeats the
Liberals and heads to Washington to
train the swamp but swamp creature Ron
DeSantis is about to start his third
term in Congress and he's already voted
repeatedly to cut Social Security and
Medicare
2017. Trump passes huge tax cuts for
nearly everyone and Ron DeSantis he's
pushing a bill that would swap those tax
cuts for a new 23 national sales tax now
that's pretty dishonest I don't know
does anybody in my audience know what
the 23 percent thing is with the Sanctus
just add just just as a very informal
survey yes no in the chat do you even
know what that's about because it's
actually extraordinarily dishonest what
Trump is doing I'm not saying I'm for or
against it
exactly everybody's a no
DeSantis had the idea
of
replacing income taxes and estate taxes
and a bunch of other taxes with one flat
23 sales tax for everybody this would
have been a massive handout to the very
rich so while it is not wrong that
DeSantis had this idea
it wasn't just like add 23 tax to
everybody that it's crazy right so so
it's extraordinarily dishonest now I
would be against it for but in order to
even talk about it honestly you have to
admit what it is speaking families paid
more
2018. it would make rich people pay much
less Trump is building a wall securing
the Border fighting The Invasion while
Ron DeSantis is voting against funding
for Trump's wall in Washington one was a
leader and one let us down even DeSantis
admitted there are big differences
between him and Trump obviously there is
because I voted contract to him in the
car Trump defeats okay 26. uh it's all
very very stupid as you can all tell and
then desperate for relevance is Nikki
Haley I know many of you are like wait
Nikki Haley's still running she is she
is desperate for relevance and the best
she can come up with is just scaling up
anti-trans rhetoric she's like I don't
know no one's paying attention to me
what if I'd be become a transphobe
here's what she came up with earlier
today
we've got biological
logic my daughter ran track in high
school
I wouldn't even know how to have that
conversation with her how do we get our
girls comfortable with biological Boys
in their locker room
it's not okay
everybody know about Dylan Mulvaney
Bud Light right there you go everybody
know about that
make no mistake that is a guy dressed up
like a girl making fun of women women
don't act like that
yet everybody's wondering why a third of
our teenage girls
seriously contemplated suicide last year
yeah actually we have data about why so
many teenage girls had suicidal ideation
unrestricted access to social media for
13 to 17 year olds in particular girls
seems to be absolutely toxic absolutely
toxic so Nikki Haley is kind of like no
one's paying attention to me maybe I'll
make some transphobic comments now
tomorrow on the program the podcast the
pcast as the kids these days call it I
will break down a little more this issue
of so-called men in women's sports and
you really have to give the subject
uh fair treatment I would say in many
sports it actually doesn't really matter
in the sports where muscle mass seems to
be a determining characteristic of an
advantage you then have to say well okay
what do we do in those particular Sports
and it's a relatively small number some
people have said ban trans women from
participating others have said set up
assist NCAA has done this already is it
set up a system where doctors
essentially sign off based on
um hormonal levels to say you can
participate others have said start a
third category for Trans athletes you
know none of these Solutions is perfect
but the point is
you take all issues then you say well
gender issues issues related to uh trans
uh then you go issues related to
transports okay within that it's trans
women because you know nobody's saying
oh kick the trans men out of sports and
then the sports within that slice that
it makes a difference in and that's
where we have to figure it out so it's
like you know these people pretending
that this is the foremost issue she says
it's the number one issue for her
daughter or whatever she's out of her
out of her mind some people say band
Sports
that's another idea uh some very very
strange things happening behind me as
people can uh as people can tell all
right we are moments away from the Ron
DeSantis campaign launch let me thank
some really great people crowbars
forever mechanically reclaimed meat New
Hampshire fog and Breezy for the twitch
Prime subscriptions that pushes us to
six huge thank you to Jason sickmeyer
and Kevin gouldi each of whom just
gifted subscriptions at joinpakman.com
folks we are in it we are in the 2024
Republican primary I would venture to
say that this primary as a contested
primary the likes of which we will never
have seen in retrospect when it's over
starts today and I implore you to sign
up on my website using this code 24
starts now 24 starts now that will save
you gobs of cash at joinpakman.com Jake
Russo just did it and signed up on my
website website thank you uh thank you
Jake Jake is new member number nine
today couple other updates the David
packman uh Spotify album is really
really really close to completion
honestly what we're waiting right now
before distribution is an album cover
um what we're workshopping right now is
me in a sea of mangoes sort of like a
ball pit but it's mangoes instead of a
ball pit we have one person working on
it if other people want to make
submissions the thing to look up if you
want to make a submission for the album
cover and then maybe we can even do a
contest is Google CD baby we're using CD
Baby for distribution CD Baby album art
requirements and it'll tell you exactly
what the specs are if you'd like to make
a submission send it to info
davidpackman.com so that's happening
soon very soon the children's book on
critical thinking will be available for
pre-order and we're going to be looking
at pre-orders so strongly that you can't
even imagine
um potentially I mean I think it I think
if we if we launch the pre-orders
correctly
um we have a shot at making some kind of
Amazon list for children's book uh and I
think that that would be uh an
absolutely beautiful beautiful thing to
do okay we are moments away from this
major announcement in which Ron DeSantis
will say he is running big thank you to
Desiree Delong who just signed up on my
website using the coupon code 24 24
starts now also thanks to Ocean phantom
for re-upping the twitch Prime
subscription very much appreciate it uh
people asking how long is this event
going to be I have no idea no idea will
our book on critical thinking be banned
in Florida honestly that's a damn good
question uh there are people who who
wrote to me and said David when the book
is out I'm going to buy a bunch of
copies and uh send them make them
available give them to school libraries
I honestly I don't think it's out of the
question that Florida might ban our book
on critical thinking for kids and if
that happens you know I will tell you
and we will uh get as much uh as much
mileage out of that as possible let's go
to some super chats any thoughts on
Brian Tyler Cohen hitting 2 million
subscribers on YouTube I didn't know
that he did but congratulations to Brian
uh Brian and I uh chat frequently it's
funny I uh I essentially don't use my
phone
um I I just I just don't use it I don't
I don't talk on the phone one of the
only people I talk to on the phone is
Brian Tyler Cohen he will just randomly
call me and uh yeah congratulations to
him that's awesome and we want to we
want to get there as soon as we can
folks as soon as we can we want to get
to 2 million as well kg says why did you
call your show a p cast did the urine
drinking have an effect on the show
exactly right very clever very very
extraordinarily clever welcome to
Alexander lensicki who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code 24
starts now welcome to Nation Farabee who
is new member 13 today on the website
with the coupon code 24 starts now we
are standing by on Elon musk's Twitter
spaces this event is scheduled to start
oh here we go here we go
it is starting
see what's going on here
I don't know why we can't hear anything
anybody know if it's actually started
yet why aren't we able to hear anything
do you know
do we know what's going on
I mean we're in
Jenna Ellis is here it hasn't started
yet okay very very good very good
let's see if we can crop this correctly
here we go yeah see look at some of the
people here
uh uh Tomy Lauren is there
Trump's former lawyer Jenna Ellis is
here a lot of interesting folks here
Justin Amash all right so we're standing
by
will it crash that's a good question
that's a good question
all right okay so this is starting any
second any second welcome to blood blood
Buzz choreo and Beth Graham thank you
for the twitch Prime subscriptions very
much appreciate it
um super chat's continuing to come in
Sebastian amenoff says nothing with a 20
Euro Super Chat very much appreciate
that let's see if we can dump in a
voicemail or two before they uh start
here
um
see what we got
hey Dave it's Tommy don't mind the audio
in the background I'm pushing my
granddaughter on a swing but uh
I think meatball Ron
uh has about the same chance as a
meatball covered in ketchup on the plate
of one Donald J Trump oh yeah that's an
import so I mean listen if we want to
look at the polling
desantis's polling is basically in the
toilet but since news broke what is
happening with my hair it's crazy I got
a haircut today I haven't showered yet
it's just a mess uh I might as well just
embrace it let's just do this
there we go
um
DeSantis has gotten a little bump
from the news that he would be
announcing so I don't know I still I
mean Trump doesn't need any more support
he's over 50 already
but uh
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens
um
let's see what else we've got here
90 000 people are standing by for this
event by the way it genuinely hasn't
started right because we can't hear
anything but I think it's just let's see
nothing's muted okay it seems like it
just hasn't started yet
Mike boy for mayor and Harry have just
re-upped twitch Prime subscriptions very
much appreciate that welcome to you guys
also a big thank you to Jim Frank and
Marta Garcia both of whom just signed up
on my website folks I've I consider that
the 2024 Republican primary really
starts today
and as a result we have launched the
coupon code 24 starts now I invite you
to join your fellow
I don't know you know fellow critical
thinkers uh at joinpakman.com and use
that coupon code 24 starts now other
super chats coming in Tristan says will
anything stop Republicans doing this
debt ceiling random BS every time they
get a chance is there any sort of
Safeguard possible you can I be totally
honest with you guys I am not even
paying attention well my hair is so
staticky it's crazy I'm not even paying
attention to the debt ceiling thing
because there are so many other things
going on and it's the same routine every
whatever 18 months and I know that
it will affect people if we default
but uh
it's just how much time am I going to
devote to the exact same circular thing
people are saying test out another
Twitter space to see if we have audio
let's see Twitter spaces
let's see what we have here
it's not clear to me how to even find
other spaces anybody know
it seems there's no audio yet
can anyone in the audience confirm that
there is not yet any audio from this
event
anybody
confirmed okay very good very very good
very good yeah you know um Faron cousins
texted me this morning and he said I
want to direct people to some other way
to see the de Sanctus announcement
rather than Twitter are you streaming
and I said I am uh I would very much
suggest just listen on our stream in
order to reduce the traffic on Twitter
to the extent that we care about that I
don't know that's something thanks to
Bowflex man as well as Alice for the
twitch Prime subscriptions very much
appreciate that
um you know what let's do this if we get
to a hundred today during the stream
I'll open up the phone lines right after
the de Sanctus uh announcement
um Ron DeSantis has joined so we should
be hearing something very soon
very very soon absolutely let's listen
to a couple other voicemails uh people
as well hello this is uh JC Colfax from
Colorado and uh your program today
brought up a weird thing between my me
and my sister because we text about
politics and I had to start referring to
Ron DeSantis as wrong just to make it
easy to text and I was wondering if you
or anyone else out there can think of a
better shorter or name to call this
freak yeah rather freak wrong to Sanctus
is one that a lot of people seem to like
but I'm not big on the nicknames I
really am not
um okay thanks to The Phantom Menace for
a 50 Super Chat never underestimate
anyone not even meatball Rob anything is
possible I like the Jared Leto 30
Seconds to Mars look by the way David
keep up the great work
I love you Dad okay very good uh very
much appreciate that other super chats
coming in Sebastian says will the
primary damage Trump's general election
chances depends how the primary goes
depends how many more times Trump gets
arrested and indicted it seems like it
will be like at least once more I don't
know
um
but you know it there's a lot of ifs
ands and buts surrounding this campaign
that's for damn sure that's for damn
sure
uh
uh rated Roy and snorts D have re-upped
twitch Prime subscriptions as has
k12412 putting us at 24 for the evening
we should be just moments away from the
start and here we go
oh boy we've got an audio problem
already
thanks to cubaimus for the twitch Prime
subscription
someone's Whispering did you hear that
that was the Sanctus Whispering did you
guys hear that
all right
uh good afternoon good evening or good
morning everyone depending on wherever
in the world you're joining us from I'm
broadcasting live from David from
Twitter headquarters it's David sax here
uh Elon is sitting next to me and we
want and we want to welcome you to this
historic Twitter spaces event and more
broadly at first in the history of
social media uh tonight I'm pleased to
introduce two individuals who've done
more to lose
we just lost audio
the audio is gone
this is a historic event
oh god oh dear God isn't this the best
uh I just love it thanks Andre for the
twitch Prime subscription one so they
got about what was that 20 seconds in
absolutely historic event
all right sorry about that we we've got
so many people here that I think we are
we are uh kind of melting the servers
they're melting inside
um all right I'd like to just introduce
the the uh the folks in in the room here
so it's safe to say we wouldn't be
making history without the man sitting
next to me Elon Musk his decision to
purchase this platform last year was a
disaster permission as a beacon for free
speech and even to expose Twitter's past
complicity with a government-censorship
regime
might have surprised many but not those
of us who've known to work with Elon for
nearly a quarter Century
Government Elite institutions and
corporate media uh go ahead and send a
heart up if you want to say thank you
Elon thank you no thank you uh Governor
DeSantis first Drew my attention and
support when I saw how he responded to
the covet pandemic and refused to
believe what we now know to be the many
falsehoods that government experts their
media mouthpieces were feeding us he
kept Florida schools open and this
economy thriving while my state of
California chose two years of learning
loss and lockdowns that we have yet to
full
we lost audio again wow three major
audio breakdowns in the first
three minutes this is this is going so
well this is just the best Des Sanctus
is gone I just realized the Sanctus is
gone from the event
oh God this is the best it is historic I
have I have to admit guys they're right
it is absolutely historic this this is
the best David you got your audio glitch
which I on the podcast today I said what
I'm hoping for is Major technology
problems during this historic event and
this is over performing even my
estimates this is as disastrous as a
SpaceX launch oh God
apparently antifa is running audio
thanks rakaja for the twitch Prime
subscription
if there's ever been a better day to use
the coupon code 24 starts now on my
website then today I can't think of it
um I guess everybody's gone the guy who
was speaking is gone and Des Sanctus is
gone
imagine if they can't even make the
announcement like what's what's Geniuses
genius in its Insanity DeSantis already
filed to run at 2 24 PM earlier we know
he's running and the whole point of this
event is for him to run to announce
and he's quite literally disconnected
let's see so now it's Elon yeah yeah I
think so
um just to simplify that
now they're gone again fourth audio
problem
fourth audio problem
let's just tweet here that's one thing
we're just gonna use your
we're six minutes into the DeSantis
spaces event and we're up to four major
audio tech problems so far
maybe prayer does work
they're off again I guess this is the
fifth issue now
do you guys think it's possible that I I
willed these problems into existence
all right great so let's see
someone in the back
and just a massive number of people
online so it's um service restraining
somewhat
um
DeSantis reportedly has released a
Twitter video
announcing the campaign
continued issues continued struggle
this is this is the absolute best I
could have hoped for it really is
I don't see any descendants Twitter
video
this is his latest post
um
this is this is hilarious on his
personal page oh okay
let's see Ron DeSantis
people
I guess it's this one
here it is here's the announcement
our border is a disaster
all right we're just reallocating more
uh civil capability uh to be able to
handle load here it's really going going
crazy so
um yeah I'm actually very excited to
um have uh Governor Sanders uh make this
uh
and he's gone
wow this is gold you could not script
this any more humiliatingly
this is just the best
listen we're not going to be on woke
YouTube Florida's where woke goes to die
we're gonna do it on Twitter spaces and
it's gonna work perfectly
man
it's over right guys like
it's over
this may be the greatest moment ever on
Twitter
this may genuinely be the best moment in
the history of Twitter
um
all right let's look at a little more of
the announcement tests are cities the
federal government makes it harder for
families to make ends meet and the
president flounders but decline is a
choice success is attainable and freedom
is worth fighting for writing the ship
requires restoring sanity to our society
normalcy to our communities and
integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation and Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue in Florida we prove that it can
be done we chose facts over fear
education over indoctrination remember
that Florida's completely mediocre in
every category it's in the 20s in
education it's in the it's it's a
completely mediocre state with great
weather Law and Order over rioting and
disorder we held the line when Freedom
hung in the bounds we showed that we can
and must Revitalize America we need the
courage to lead and the strength to win
I'm ronji santis and I'm running oh my
God he's going back to the old
pronunciation do you guys know about
this he used to say his name DeSantis
and then over the last several years he
stopped that he seems to be he's running
as a different person he's back to
DeSantis for president to lead our Great
American comeback
wow this smile right here
you guys see this
this is not the smile of a guy I want to
see as president of the United States
uh okay
so um
the Twitter spaces event is still
it's still going but it's basically dead
imagine putting you know
think about the poetically disastrous
nature of what is taking place right
here Elon Musk buys Twitter under the
pretense that it's not working right and
nobody you know it's politically going
the wrong way and all these different
things he's going to fix it he's going
to improve it then all of a sudden they
say we're going to make a historic
announcement we're going to get this
presidential uh announcement it's going
to be incredible it's going to be great
this is going to be the start of Twitter
as the place for politics we're going to
be the central hub for 2024's election
and then they can't even do an audio
feed
they can't even do an audio feed it's
it's a stunning stunning situation
this should end Twitter in a sense
wow
let's see what's going on with Trump's
truth
let's see if he's making fun of it
uh tweeting polls his collar is too big
okay yeah we looked at that before so
nothing nothing really new there
do you guys think they're killing the
event because it's just as it's just a
disaster
deeper shades of house thanks for the
membership
Twitter subscription I appreciate that
uh
uh let's see what we got here
I mean this whole thing might just be
dying I don't know if they're going to
be able to even get it
have they called it off does anybody
know let's see if I refresh elon's
Twitter
hmm
seems like I even exited the thing now
seems dead
hmm
it does seem to have died to some degree
it's all totally glitchy I think I got
ejected yeah
they kicked me out it seems like
hmm
well what a complete and total disaster
complete and total anyone else keep
getting booted
look at the it's just totally glitched
it's glitching badly really really badly
people are just getting kicked out
hmm
wow it's totally dead well guys you know
they promised a historic day and I
absolutely believe that we got it it
really does seem that this is a historic
day
welcome to jtand away and rubbing your
rhubarb with the twitch Prime
subscriptions I appreciate that
um
I mean I guess we'll we'll just refresh
and maybe we can get tyt reported that
the event is over
oh these people this is just amazing
this is real this is the best possible
outcome I have to say nobody suppressed
anybody's speech they quite literally
just couldn't get the tech working
there's no liberal censorship it's just
it's just all they they just couldn't
they just couldn't do it
wow
wow look at this
this is really wild it's really cancel
culture
Twitter is where woke goes to die
man
well
interesting
interesting campaign
um
he really is brilliant isn't he
who am I talking about I don't even know
let's see what people are saying via
super chats won't it be great if
Tucker's Twitter show goes just as well
exactly
this event isn't even trending on
Twitter what a great disaster
okay we're not doing covid right now
uh I don't know how much longer we wait
before we say that it's dead
isn't this disaster absolutely
the best thing to ever happen on Twitter
wow
well
trust me he's running even though the
announcement was bungled he published
his own video saying he's running
welcome Margo
uh oh let's see hold on oh play a
recording it's over they've called yeah
I guess it's dead I guess that's the
whole thing
I guess that's the whole thing let's see
if we can play the end of it
let's see how they wrapped it up
silence
but see if there's anything here
is it just silent till the very end
sorry oh wait let's see they said
something hold on
there was like there was one minute all
right like to welcome uh Governor
DeSantis uh for this so I start
Ed
just trying to get it going because it's
there's so many people
that's unfortunate I'd like to have
never seen this before
oh my God
what an embarrassment what an
embarrassment
and then these are we're just listening
to the last 15 seconds to see if
anything else was said
it genuinely is getting better and
better
seven six and this it seems like they
just killed it
David sacks posted a new space
let's see David sacks whoops
let's see
they're starting over this one's dead as
well
okay we'll see if we can get into this
one this is just the best thing that
could possibly happen here we go
we're starting over
thank you
wow
um super chats keep coming in
check out Biden's reaction I saw it he
said here's a link that works
today's podcast is stuck processing any
word when it will be available please
email in for tech support I I don't I
don't know what's going on
welcome to lyanna Spencer appreciate the
twitch Prime subscription if you were
just joining us the first Twitter space
went horribly wrong
they weren't even able to make the
announcement
David sacks now posted a new Twitter
space which we're waiting for desantisan
it's the worst possible rollout of what
oh all right here we go
here we go again
typing
a lot of hot mic problems huh
okay does this die or not all right I
think we're broadcasting man I think we
melted the internet there yeah that was
insane sorry we
uh I'm actually doing this from David
Sax's Twitter account uh because uh it
looks like doing it from mine basically
broke the Twitter system
um anyway thanks everyone for joining uh
we're incredibly excited to announce uh
that if you want to have uh coming to
send us uh on with us with just a
historic announcement
um and I look forward to a little live q
a from uh the audience so the audience
yeah with that yeah I mean so uh
Governor Santos uh can are you there can
you hear us I'm gonna try to get on I'm
here I know I think I think you broke
the internet there we had over half a
million people in one Twitter space and
it was growing by like 50 000 a minute
so uh congrats on uh on Breaking the
internet there well yeah yeah I mean he
tries to you know new things you're
gonna yes uh it's adventurous so yes
um this is so yeah I think the the value
here is actually really high for people
to hear directly from presidential
candidates and to answer q a live and
you can get a sense for it didn't even
announcement it really is you know and
where it's not just canned speeches and
uh teleprompters uh it's uh you in fact
you can tell by the you know some of the
mistakes that that it's real yeah so
um you know with with that I I guess I
should turn it over
to um yeah well let's see so yeah
Governor there's been a lot of
speculation over the last couple of
months about your your plans this is
terrible I understand that you may have
an announcement to make uh we've got I
think a record audience assembled here
uh you know the probably the biggest uh
room that's probably ever been assembled
online uh what what would you like to
tell them I don't think that's true
for president of the United States to
lead our Great American comeback look we
know our country's going in the wrong
direction we see it with our eyes and we
feel it in our bones our Southern
borders collapse drugs are pouring into
the country our cities are being
hollowed out by spiking crime the
federal government's making it harder
for the average family to make ends meet
and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
well he lacks Vigor flounders in the
face of our nation's challenges and he
takes his cues from the woke mob I don't
think it has to be this way America's
decline is not inevitable it is a choice
and we should choose a new Direction a
path that will lead to American
revitalization we must restore sanity to
our nation this means embracing fiscal
and economic sanity stop pricing
hard-working there's no way a guy with a
voice this annoying becomes president
right like there's just no way in hell
race Amir American Energy Independence
this also means replacing the woke mind
virus with reality facts and enduring
principles Merit must Trump identity
politics we must return normalcy to our
communities America is a sovereign
country our borders must be respected we
cannot have foreigners pouring into our
country illegally by the millions we
cannot allow drug cartels to poison our
population with fentanyl public deserve
safe communities and Law and Order must
be maintained in American cities we
can't have inmates running the Asylum
how soon will we get an audio Loop
feedback situation what do you think we
also must re-establish Integrity in our
institutions this includes the military
I'm proud to be a Navy veteran and Iraq
veteran and I Revere our services but
when revered institutions like those in
our military are more concerned with
matters not Central to the mission
whether it's global warming or gender
ideology G and pronouns morale declines
and recruiting suffers and you need to
eliminate these distractions and we need
to get focused on the core Mission we
also cannot have true constitutional
government if the most significant
issues are decided by the whims of
unelected bureaucrats rather than the
people's elected representatives
re-establishing Integrity in our
institutions means we must reinvigorate
our constitution this is so dumb by
returning the government to its rightful
owners We the People no social or Eco
transformation without representation
truth needs to be our foundation Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue and in Florida we proved it could
be done we chose facts over fear
education over indoctrination Law and
Order over rioting and disorder we held
the line when Freedom hung into balance
the nation's fastest growing State we're
number one in net in migration number
one in new business formations recently
ranked number one in education we have a
50-year low crime rate and one of the
lowest tax in debt per capita in America
but we also understand governing is not
entertainment it's not about building a
brand or virtue signaling it is about
delivering results and our results in
Florida have been second to none and we
can and we must deliver big results for
America I pledge to be an energetic
executive that will take on the
important issues Biden's pursued
inflationary policies that are hurting
working people we will reverse those
policies and we'll build an economy
where working Americans can achieve a
good standard of living Biden's opened
the southern border and allowed massive
amounts of drugs it's closed or into the
country we'll shut down the Border
construct the border wall and hold the
drug cartels accountable bidens Embrace
medical authoritarianism such as
unconstitutional covid back tax mandates
we will ensure that those violations of
Liberty can never happen again Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda totally will never surrender to
the woke mob never we will leave woke
ideology in the Dustbin of History how
many times has he said woke so far
military and cause recruiting to plummet
we will eliminate ideological agendas
from our military Focus the military on
the core Mission and we will reverse the
poor recruiting Trends finally Biden's
weaponized the power of the
administrative state to advance his
left-wing agenda we will
reconstitutionalize the executive branch
and we'll bring the administrative state
to heal now you can't do any of that if
you don't win there is no substitute for
victory we must then the culture of
losing that has infected the Republican
party in recent years the tired dogmas
of the past are inadequate for a vibrant
future
he sounds so natural reading this drivel
we need the courage to lead and we must
have the strength to win and to voters
who are participating in this primary
process my pledge to you is this if you
nominate me you can set your clock to
January 20th 2025 at High Noon because
on the west side of the U.S Capitol I
will be taking the oath of office as the
47th president of the United States no
excuses I will get
oh oh
he'll get what
another tech issue it seems
what is he gonna get no excuses for what
hmm
I guess it's dead
he's gonna get muted apparently
wow
let's see if they fixed it
I guess we'll never know yeah or care
exactly nicely done nicely done the
production value on this announcement is
just a bit amazing
I'm sure they'll only allow uh verified
accounts to ask questions since I don't
pay the eight bucks I'm not verified
anymore
um but I'll try I'll try to ask a
question if they ever get to that
I would blame antifa for all of this
each generation would have a
responsibility
you didn't even pause our responsibility
to do so with this important juncture in
our nation's history we have a lot of
work to do to ensure the country gets
back on track I ask everybody listening
to please join me on this Mission please
invest in our campaign by going to
rondesantis.com take my money making a
donation thank you God bless and I look
forward to the discussion discussion
all right thank you Governor appreciate
that um I guess just a as a first uh
follow-up uh here thank you for putting
up with these technical issues I think
we're definitely breaking new ground
here as far as I know uh no major
presidential candidate has ever
announced uh their their uh their
candidacy uh on social media let's wait
to see if he's a major candidate thank
you for doing that uh what made you want
to kind of take the chance of doing it
this way as opposed to just doing it on
cable reserve the the usual way well I'm
kind of a well when covid hit I
had to make decisions about do you go
with the crowd or do you look at the
data yourself and cut Against the Grain
and I chose to do the latter I faced
huge blowback uh for doing that from the
bureaucracy from the leads from the
media but my view is I had to look out
for the people I represented prefer
protecting their jobs over trying to
safeguard my own political hide but it
was very very lonely and a lot of those
decisions and part of the reason it was
so lonely is because there there was a
concerted this is a really weird
explanation for why are you doing this
on Twitter narrative about
during covid and it was an Orthodoxy
being enforced by the major Tech
Platforms in conjunction with the
federal government and if we can't have
an honest debate and a free country
about issues that affect hundreds of
millions of people like lockdowns and
what good is the first amendment at that
point those are precise did we have
lockdowns I still don't remember them
you robust you should not be taking down
articles that criticize those Draconian
policies and yet that's exactly what
happened so it occurred to me that if
that had continued I think free speech
in this in this country was on its way
out the door and so when Elon Musk
stepped up to purchase Twitter he paid a
lot of money for it uh and I'm sure
because he's a good businessman Elon I'm
sure you'll you'll end up making money
off it but the bottom line is you had to
put your money where your mouth is
because I think you recognize that uh
you can't have a free Society unless we
have the freedom to debate the most
important issues that are affecting our
civilization that did not happen during
covid the truth was censored repeatedly
and now that Twitter is in the hands of
of a free speech Advocate right that
would not be able to happen again uh on
this Twitter platform so I think what
was done with Twitter is really
significant for the future of our
country we cannot have a society in
which government is colluding with major
Tech platforms to enforce an Orthodoxy
thank you um yeah I'm here because
Snapchat has gone totally woke and just
a vigorous debate and hopefully uh this
can be a platform that brings people of
Divergent political views uh to exchange
those views and and have some Minds will
be changed one way or the other and um
but it's just incredibly it's a free
speech platform where Free Speech costs
eight bucks a month irrelevant if uh all
the media and all the and the government
are operating in lockstown it's uh it
makes you know the most important
Amendment the one that was most urgently
added to the Constitution
um moot if you if you cannot have a free
and open debate
um so
yeah so Twitter was indeed expensive uh
but free speech is priceless
okay
awesome
um thank you so uh Governor let me I'm
gonna ask some questions while we get
some other uh kind of speakers in the
queue to ask questions let's see if I
can try to put some people knew this
announcement was coming because there's
been no shortage of hit pieces on you
yeah in the Press over the last week or
two I want to ask you about some of
these accusations that are being leveled
at you uh last week uh the NAACP issued
a travel advisory against your state
claiming that Florida is not a safe
place for minorities to visit uh what do
you say to those who've been advised
that somehow they are welcoming well
they're totally wrong claiming that
Florida is unsafe is a total farce I
mean are you kidding me you look at
cities around this country have you gone
woke crime in Florida our crime rate is
at a 50-year low if you look at the top
25 cities for crime in America Florida
does not have a single one amongst the
top 25 and if you look at cities like
Baltimore and Chicago you got kids more
likely to get shot than to receive a
first class education yet I don't see
the NAACP batting an eye about all the
outrage and the Carnage that's happening
in those areas so this is a political
stunt these left-wing groups have been
doing it for many many years and at the
end of the day what they're doing is
colluding with Legacy Media to try to
manufacture a narrative now the good
news is is fewer and fewer Americans are
gullible enough to believe this dribble
and platforms like Twitter are there
where people can debunk these lies in
real time and I would just say as an
American citizen if you are uncritically
accepting narrative spun by Legacy Media
and left-wing groups you're failing at
your job of being a conscientious
Citizen and I think people just see
right through it and oh by the way have
any of these travel advisories because
they've been doing this for for a while
these left-wing groups have any of them
worked well we're the number one state
for net and migration and have been
every year since I've been Governor we
just capped the highest quarter for
tourism in the history of the State of
Florida and our view is we want
everybody to succeed regardless of their
skin color we don't divvy up people by
race at the same time it is worth
pointing out that we have in Florida
more black owned businesses than any
state in the nation and we've also had
more African Americans lead State
agencies under my Administration than at
any time in Florida history but with us
you know they're there because of Merit
not because we're trying to play
identity politics and if you want to
look at education uh the black students
in the in Florida perform much higher
than black students in most other states
we rank number three in fourth grade
reading and number two in fourth grade
math amongst our black student
population and oh by the way the head of
the NAACP a lot of fact checking to be
done here members have put out on social
media during my governorship Florida
vacations where they seem to be having
an awful good time
foreign
that's great
um well I mean Farm's great state and I
think the the people people realize that
um the the some of the things that are
being said are just truly absurd
um I mean I I saw some headline from the
Atlantic uh basically claiming that
anyone who listens listens to this uh
spaces on Twitter is basically a Nazi
um so uh or yeah
it said that uh that you were you were
uh hosting or interviewing because David
Duke wasn't available oh yes although
I'm not totally sure who they were
saying was David Duke I don't know if it
was you or Governor DeSantis is sort of
a little bit unclear but uh but I think
this is a function of these the Legacy
Media these corporate journal they're in
their little bubble and to to draw
Illusions to stuff like that I mean how
crazy do you have to be but in their
little bubble it sounds like they're
making some type of profound point and
so part of I think what Twitter is
standing for is people should be exposed
to different viewpoints and I think the
Elites in our society have tried to
Cluster themselves to where their
assumptions are never clustered here
that's not a a good way I think to live
it's also not a good way to to be a
critical thinker because no one's ever
gonna question uh obviously wrong
assumptions because everybody around you
shares them absolutely and I think they
become totally hysterical because they
don't like the idea that their control
over the media is being you know just
intermediated yeah because now you know
candidates for a president can just
speak directly to people through
platforms like Twitter yeah I mean the
the amazing so is Elon endorsing him or
not I don't get it
um although I happen to be hosting it it
well I I have to switch over to David
hosting it because my account was
actually too much interest my account
was breaking the system
um but uh it's it's uh there's really
never been a
mechanisms before where someone could
address the nation or anyone who wanted
to listen to them could from from
anywhere in the world what is he talking
about but there's never been a way to do
that before of course there has a change
um and it's also like the it's not just
whether the media reports something an
article is is true or not uh even more
powerful is deciding what the narrative
is and so uh you know it's just like if
there's only so much you can actually
fit in the newspaper or a magazine and
what and there's only one thing you can
really put on on the cover of magazines
so uh that that whoever's deciding that
is is deciding to not talk about other
things
um whereas with a public digital Town
Square like we have here it's possible
for the public to choose the narrative
it empowers the people instead of a a
very tiny Elite cabal which I don't
recognize the irony of musicians
um but but nonetheless it's like a
Twitter problem
and judge by the results that uh this is
a means for people to decide the
narrative and for the people to decide
uh What uh you know which way a debate
will go
um not sort of five editors in Chiefs of
a few newspapers basically yeah and I
think one of the really crazy things
that happened during covet is that have
you guys noticed that DeSantis hasn't
said a word for a while this is just
such an abortive attempt at an
announcement full viewpoints that ended
up being totally correct in in lockstep
with what the mainstream media was doing
so basically big Tech platforms were
undermining their main reasons for
existing which is giving people a choice
and actually there's there's somebody
who I think knows more about that than
any of us which is Dr Jay bhattacharya
who's a professor of medicine at
Stanford oh no I want to pull him in
here uh Jake again are they going to do
like anti-vax right now to hear from you
um I know that during covet you work
with Governor DeSantis it'd be great to
hear a little bit about your
interactions and if you have a question
for the governor if thank you David yeah
I mean it was it was an absolute honor
to work with uh with with Governor uh
DeSantis and I was really impressed by
his decision making in the face of an
absolute Firestorm of criticism
um but he you know Governor you did the
right thing when you opened the schools
and uh my kids in California for a year
and a half didn't see the inside of a
classroom whereas Florida kids were in
school and you can see in the results in
the learning loss numbers are so much
better in Florida uh I I I'm really
curious Governor um
you as you're running for president what
are your thoughts about reforming uh you
know the the public health authority in
the United States and the federal
government that you know the CDC the FDA
well I'm totally for it medication has
gone woke they're giving kids pink
colored antibiotics because they're
pushing gender Theory they're giving
boys pink bubble gum antibiotics an
honest Reckoning about what happened
during covid and the only honest
Reckoning is that all of those agencies
all of the elites the public health
establishment they failed they
instituted bad policies uh obviously
it's a novel virus but I think what
happened was when the data was becoming
more and more apparent that the path
they were on was wrong they doubled down
and wanted to do it even more and I
really believe had Florida not just kind
of stood in the way I think this country
would have had rolling lockdowns for
probably really a two-year period And so
their impulses were authoritarian they
were not following the data and I think
the U.S government needs to acknowledge
the failures and I think all of those
agencies need to be cleaned out what I
saw just dealing with them was I saw a
interest in the narrative and in
politics over evidence-based reasoning
and evidence-based medicine and so I
don't have confidence that those
agencies are up to the task and I think
you need major major overhaul of the
whole enchilada with respect to Public
Health in this country
we're not going to do those soft shell
tacos no way not in Florida
um the the other thing that I saw during
the pandemic governor and you you uh was
subject to it just as much as I was when
we were talking about covid YouTube
censored a video of us speaking about in
a round table that you hosted on covet
policy uh there's so much of the federal
government infrastructure went into
suppressing on a scientific discussion
during the pandemic so it's not just
public health agency but other agencies
inside the federal government that
worked to suppress the speech of
Americans and I'd love to hear your
question no question so I'm actually in
Florida we recognize that the danger
there so I'm actually going to be
signing a digital Bill of Rights for
Florida pretty soon which will very soon
state and local government officials
from colluding or working with a
technology company for the purpose of
censorship of speech because you're
exactly right you had people in the
White House you had people and all these
other agencies working with these
platforms to try to take it down and oh
by the way what did they censor Dr
bhattacharya for it was a Roundtable
discussion that I led and convened we
had Dr bhattacharya MD PhD from Stanford
we had Martin caldorf from Harvard
Medical School and we had symmetry it
looks like this Christopher Ruffo guy is
going to be the next person to speak
we'll see what the deal is with that
until she became anti-lockdown so these
are all eminent people and what are we
discussing we're discussing whether
there's any scientific basis to force a
school child to wear a mask for eight
hours a day they all agreed there was no
basis to do it and that you should not
have school Mass mandates YouTube
thought that that was quote anti-science
and that that should be taken down but
even at that point we had already had
enough experience in Florida where you
had some schools that had done it before
before the state banned the mandates you
had some schools that had done it some
schools didn't and the results were no
different and yet his video was taken
down by Google YouTube so it was a huge
huge problem and yes I this is a lot of
whining I don't know about you guys but
it's like are we going to do anything
other than wine here unconstitutional
for them to be delegating speech
restriction to a private company you
can't do indirectly what the
Constitution would clearly forbid you to
do directly
let me let me pull in uh we have uh
Congressman Thomas Massey oh God if
you're there uh he's a lunatic go ahead
and unmute yourself I mean what we're
talking about here it I think really
unconstitutional actions by federal
agencies uh Congressman Massey I know
that you've been involved in in uh this
problem of you know government agencies
being weaponized uh and and used against
the American people in an appropriate
way uh do you have a comment on this uh
and do you have a question for governor
DeSantis well first of all let me say uh
a big thank you to Elon Musk for buying
Twitter and exposing all of this on our
weaponization committee we wouldn't know
so much of it if he hadn't done this
almost as a public service to the First
Amendment right um it's a disturbing
Trend government as the guy someone
should pay Elon Musk for the Public
Service of buying Twitter found out this
week from an FBI whistleblower that bank
was my America
voluntarily gave names of and and uh
information on anybody who bought a hot
dog in Washington DC from January 5th to
January 7th and then overlaid that with
gun purchases
that they had on record anywhere in the
country for any period pretty smart they
say they voluntarily gave that to the
FBI so that's disturbing to me uh by the
way I've never met Elon Musk but I'm one
of your biggest fans and the first
Congressman to have a Tesla a monster
I'm on starlink and uh I would have
bought a power wall but I'm off the grid
and this seems awkward because like
DeSantis and his followers don't really
like electric vehicles so the Tesla
element is going to be an interesting
one and just for the record
um I I as a I was with Thomas our first
year is in Congress he's got the Tesla
but his license plate is Kentucky coal
so it's uh he's probably one of the only
people that have that disgusting thanks
for adding so
um Governor DeSantis my question to you
is you know you served here in Congress
for six years with me and um why is it
that Congress is so feckless at reining
in these government agencies and and
what do you think we need to do and if
you were president what what would you
urge Congress or what president would
you like to see something that Terrain
in this uh you know sort of overreach of
government bureaucracy
well first I think there's a lot that
the executive branch can do and I all I
will say when it comes to these agencies
we'll put we'll we'll go into this a
little bit more as the campaign goes on
to buckle up when I get in there because
the the status quo is not acceptable
um and we are going to make sure that we
reconstitutionalize this government and
these agencies are totally out of
control there's no accountability and we
are going to bring that in a very big
way now part of the reason it's gotten
so bad power's been Consolidated and
effectively a fourth branch of
government because Congress hasn't used
its two main powers that it has under
the Constitution first the power of the
purse if an agency is gauging in conduct
that is outside the realm of what is
legal or you think it's not good for the
public interest then you can remove the
funding for those for those operations
there's nothing that they're not
entitled to get the same level of
funding every year and yet Congress runs
the government on autopilot either
continuing resolutions or massive
Omnibus spending bills so these agencies
are all bulletproof they know that
they're going to end up getting
something similar or more every single
year and it creates an incentive for
them to to abuse their power the other
thing you you can do is actually
legislate so you're not delegating to
the bureaucracy key issues regarding how
to enforce federal law regardless Define
what you want all they should be doing
is implementing instead Congress will
basically give an invitation for the
bureaucracy to make really important
substantive decisions and so Congress
may never vote on something and the
bureaucracy will cite a law from 20
years ago and do things that are going
to transform our society or our country
that is not the way the founding fathers
Drew up the Constitution all right guys
well I think I've seen enough people are
starting to get fatigued from this one
of the worst presidential announcements
that I've ever seen it has the feeling
of the end of a campaign not the
beginning it feels completely Dead on
Arrival they are just corrosively buying
and promoting uh Elon Musk essentially
and and throwing bouquets at each other
we get the picture Okay Trump's losing
his mind on Truth Central we'll cover
all of it tomorrow I I don't know that
we need to keep uh doing this
um so it's it's pretty horrifying this
is going to be the most insane and
disgusting Republican primary that I
will have ever covered that's abundantly
clear but this is this is uh I mean this
is very very disgusting in every single
way and also completely uninspiring in
anyway there
DeSantis is so uninspiring it's hard to
be Trump at least
says things that fire people up they're
crazy things
they're completely insane things but at
least they fire people up
so we'll be back tomorrow we'll cover it
if people need Mercy bands because this
has been so crazy we you can request it
from the moderators and uh it's hard to
imagine this will generate too many new
supporters for DeSantis so we'll follow
all of it appreciate you joining me I
don't know that we learned anything
other than Twitter spaces glitched badly
um but I appreciate you being here with
me we'll see everybody very soon